the concept of feedback is often a
disguise for people to be political or
even occasionally nasty to me the
problem with feedback and the problem
with cander has always been that it
actually creates a framework for the
worst of human behavior and so one of
the reasons I stood up this concept of
kind cander I have been blown away by
just the word kind in front of cander as
a principle at Vayner media and Vayner X
how much that's verber to a couple of
very interesting things you may think
it's most impacted people being nicer
when they give feedback as a matter of
fact in our company it's allowed more
people to give feedback many many people
struggled with telling their friend or
acquaintance or someone they liked
working with proper feedback when it was
just feedback but as soon as it was kind
cander they could say Andrew I love you
you're a wonderful person hey you know
the way you videotape like those are
real things